hey what's going on everybody
i am dave rubin this is the reuben
report direct message for today
4 20 20 21 that's right it is 4 20.
it's national marijuana day national
weed day
national ganja day and i'm not here to
tell you to smoke weed or not smoke weed
you know my feelings
on individual liberty what you do in the
privacy of your own home
or at a park is up to you or maybe at
the movie theater
if you can go to a movie theater back in
the day when you could go to a movie
theater but i thought i would tell you
one funny story about weed to kick us
off today
because years ago i was once busted for
smoking a joint
that's right dave rubin mr
responsibility was once busted
for smoking a joint this is now about
seven years ago about 2013
2014 or so david myself
and kelly carlin who you guys may know
she's my friend who's been on the show a
couple of times
daughter of the great george carlin we
went to a journey concert i love
journey i've always loved journeys since
i first heard journey when i was maybe
five years old
we went to a journey concert in orange
county at an amphitheater
outdoor amphitheater kelly brought a
joint
we smoked some dope and we got darked on
the people behind us
told on us and security came to us
and they made us put out the joint they
actually didn't kick us out but i had to
step on a perfectly good joint at an
outdoor journey concert in oc and if
that's
not injustice if that's not systemic
injustice then i don't know what is
people
uh okay before we get to it today
there's there's so much going on i'm
super excited to be doing the show today
i
usually enjoy doing the show uh but
today i'm really feeling the flow
because there's a lot of good stuff that
we're gonna get to in just a sec as
always click that subscribe
button and uh tap that notification bell
so that maybe you see our videos in your
feed
and very quickly before we get to the
stories of the day and there is a lot
there is a lot today we're doing four
stories and they're all
kind of robust this might be the longest
episode ever
of the reuben report direct message we
shall see but before we get to any of
that
uh for those of you that are not playing
along on twitter and god bless you for
not being on there
or if you're not in my locals community
which in that case you're doing
something wrong in life uh i did make a
major announcement
this morning uh first on
reubenreport.locals.com and then on
twitter
but i'm thrilled to announce that locals
just closed
3.8 million dollars in seed funding
uh david sacks of craft ventures who was
a guest on the show about six weeks ago
or so
he led the round he is the former ceo of
paypal he has done something like 20
unicorns like the guy has just created
tons and tons of great companies we have
a whole bunch
of great people involved like true
innovators
from silicon valley and from the outside
uh naval and bellagi and jill lonsdale
and a whole bunch of people that that
you may or may not know tulsi gabbard is
an investor like we've really created
something
really just absolutely fantastic we are
rebuilding
social media bottom up community first
and this is
this is just the beginning we built just
the way i built the reuben report in
many ways the slim
trim company not reliant on all of the
big machinery
that's what we're doing with locals and
if you haven't checked out what we're
doing yet
uh reubenreport.locals.com and also just
a day or two ago
we're testing it with my community first
but we now have yearly subscriptions so
actually if you want to get two months
for free
you can just click the yearly thing at
reubenreport.logos.com
and and i'd love to see you and be part
of this and by the way we're doing a
live event
uh for subscribers only in uh in orange
county actually
we're not going back to the amphitheater
not going back there but we are doing a
live event
soon enough that's all i'll say for now
but you can find out more if you're in
the community okay real quick here are
the stories we're doing today
joe biden you know about this guy the
old guy with some cognitive problems he
is chiming in
on what's happening in minneapolis and
race
and the rioting and everything else and
he just within the last hour he just
poured
absolute gasoline on this thing made a
really horrible statement that we're
gonna
play for you uh and then donald trump
remember the orange guy that was sort of
the center of the universe for about
five years and then he got de-personed
he got de-platformed he got destroyed
well he was back on sean hannity
last night we're gonna play a little
clip of that and uh my gut feeling like
we're gonna play in a sec but like my
gut feeling after the little two-minute
clip you're gonna see it was like
man i miss that guy so we're gonna play
the biden clip and then we're gonna play
that and you tell me
which one of these guys is saying
something closer to something that is
true and something that is actually
american and then we've got a whole
bunch
from florida the state that is calling
me
because ron desantis signed a couple
things into law they're not going to be
defunding the police they're going to
allow for protests but you can't destroy
property
and all that other stuff and then
finally we are playing one extra clip
this morning because i just saw this but
if you thought aoc was stupid
if you thought that aoc was ridiculous
if you thought that aoc would be
better served in a mental institution
than the united states congress although
really what's the difference
well then we've got just the clip for
you so we're going to do all that
and more as you can see i'm feeling good
people
before we get to it you know when you're
running a business hr issues can kill
you
wrongful termination suits minimum wage
requirements labor regulations the list
goes on and on
and hr manager salaries aren't cheap at
an average of seventy thousand dollars a
year
bambi spelled b-a-m-b-e-e was
specifically created for small business
you can get a dedicated hr manager craft
hr policy and maintain your compliance
all for just 99 a month with bambi you
can transform
hr from your biggest liability to your
greatest strength your dedicated hr
manager is available by phone email or
real-time chat from onboarding to
terminations they customize your
policies to fit your business and help
you manage your employees day-to-day all
for just 99 bucks a month
month to month no hidden fees cancel any
time if you're like me then i bet you
didn't start your business because you
wanted to spend all your time on hr
compliance and now that i have two
businesses i assure you that's true
let bambi help get your free hr audit
today go to bambi.com
ruben right now to schedule your free hr
on it that's bambi.com
ruben spelled bam to the b-e-e dot com
slash reuben
and now back to me okay so let's just
throw right into this video
uh joe biden just in the last hour has
commented
on the trial of derek shovin who is
obviously the
minnesota police officer who was on
trial for
the death of george floyd and really
listen to what joe biden just said
knowing
that we know riots are coming riots have
already been happening we know riots are
coming
and that we're supposed to have
something in this country called the
presumption of innocence there is a
reason that that lady outside the court
is blindfolded there's a reason that you
have a trial
and a peer jury and all of those things
now listen to the president
i can only imagine the pressure and
anxiety they're feeling
and so i waited till the jury was
sequestered
and uh and i called and as i wasn't
going to say anything about it but
felonious said today on television and
they accurately said it was a private
conversation
because joe understands what it's like
to go through laws and um
they're a good family and they're
calling for
peace and tranquility no matter what
that verdict is
i'm praying the verdict is the right
verdict which is i think it's
overwhelming in my view
i wouldn't say that unless the the jury
was sequestered now
not hear me say that but so we just
talked to well i want to know how they
were doing just personally and we
talked about personal things ah joe joe
joe
joe joe i'm praying that the verdict is
the right verdict
that is the president of the united
states making it very clear that he
wants
a guilty verdict and that if a guilty
verdict doesn't happen for whatever just
happened in the trial joe doesn't
mention any of the specifics in the
trial
or the drugs in george floyd's system or
whether the cop did
the right thing or not or the negligence
or the training or any of those things
and that's actually a completely
separate issue
what the president of the united states
just did was basically set up a
situation
that he's praying that if he doesn't get
the quote right verdict wow we got a
problem
we got a problem on our hands that is an
extraordinary amount of gasoline
that he just threw on this fire and we
know that minneapolis is about to blow
up we know what's been going on
in brooklyn center and let's not forget
joe while he's praying that we get the
right verdict
uh he's the same guy who during the
presidential campaign said that antifa
is just an idea
now if you live in portland or if you
live in seattle or certainly if you live
in minneapolis or if you live in l.a or
you live in new york or
a whole bunch of other places you know
that the idea
of antifa is the thing that's burning
everything down and now we know
how closely in cahoots they are with
black lives matter and that these
activists are
openly calling basically for the
destruction of the united states they're
rampaging
through our cities destroying public
property destroying private property
attacking federal courts
courthouses this is going on and on and
on by the way uh just as a sort of
sidebar to all of this just yesterday
because every now and again somebody
will say to me well you know dave you
rag on cnn a lot but that jake tapper
ain't so bad that jake tapper's pretty
good
uh and by the way jake tapper about five
six years ago when he was on abc news i
think he was the chief white house
correspondent if i'm not mistaken he
actually was pretty good and then
there's something that happens
when you move to cnn that's like being
drugged in the head with
a big hammer or something but i quickly
glanced at his twitter feed yesterday
and i looked at his last like 50 tweets
and there was nothing about riot
so again this is like one of those fake
news things where if you follow certain
people and they don't tell you what's
actually going on and then
you know more riots come because you
don't hear exactly what happened in the
trial and everything else
you're just shocked when when reality
smashes you in the face
anyway what biden did there was so
dangerous you know we have
a judicial system and it may not be
perfect
and there's all sorts of issues that we
could discuss about policing and all of
these things as i keep saying
but the fact that the president
basically said
that he's praying no not basically he
said i am praying the verdict is the
right
verdict implying like i know what i need
to know and we better get that
conviction
and by the way we know they're going to
riot either way we know the riots are
coming no matter what like mark my words
i don't think that that really takes an
extraordinary brain to figure that out
so that is seriously dangerous but if
you don't think that's dangerous
what's going on with joe biden and all
of my very smart
liberal friends you know who always said
you know we just must get rid of orange
man
so that joe biden will make it
easier for us to fight the crazy lefties
because trump is so polarizing and joe
biden won't be that bad well i don't
know that there's
literally anything that joe biden has
done that hasn't exacerbated all of the
bad ideas that
many of the decent liberals and then of
course the conservatives and
libertarians have been fighting against
for a long time so we've got a quote
here from the national review because
biden is basically putting critical race
theory back in schools
let's remember trump took great critical
race theory out of
schools here is national review biden's
department of education has just
released the text of a proposed new rule
establishing priorities for grants
in american history and civics education
program
that rule gives priority to grant
projects that incorporate racially
ethnically culturally and linguistically
diverse perspectives
the rule goes on to cite and praise the
new york times landmark 1619
project as well as the work of critical
race theorist kenny
as leading examples of the sort of ideas
the biden administration wants
to spread okay so let me be crystal
clear about this
the biden administration and again i say
the biden administration not old joe
because none of this is coming
from his handicapped brain is now
in effect anti-american that is what it
is the 16-19 project which many
of the ideas in the 16-19 project have
been debunked the idea that the founding
principle of the united states was
slavery as opposed to freedom i mean
this is a crazy proposition
the idea that the anti-racist book by
kendy
would be something that you would want
in the system they are
institutionalizing racism in our public
schools they are institutionalizing
systemic racism
into our system they are doing the
reverse of mlk
and all of that stuff i know you guys
get it but we got to get more people to
get
it and if you don't think that's bad
enough well there's more coming
because the fbi is appointing its first
chief
diversity officer this is from homeland
security today
director for christopher wray has
formally appointed scott mcmillan
as the fbi's first chief diversity offer
in officer in this role mr mcmillan will
direct the office of diversity and
inclusion
okay so again nobody cares what your
color
is nobody cares what your gender is
nobody cares what your sexuality is
or any of that stuff once we put these
departments
into all of these institutions into all
of these businesses into all of these
governmental organizations they slowly
well i don't want to say slowly
in many cases very quickly rot them from
the inside i don't care
if my local fbi agent is black or white
or gay or
trans okay i want them to be competent
this is the same thing with a doctor
i if i had a heart problem i would want
to go to the best doctor
i wouldn't want to go well i'm sorry i'm
going to have to have a black lesbian
doctor that would be best
for me sure you know i've got this hard
thing we got to work this out but sorry
whitey
i'm not racist i'm an anti-racist and i
demand
that that my heart surgery be
done by a black lesbian preferably with
a lazy eye would that be possible
because that would help you know what i
mean this is all dangerous stuff so
they are bringing critical race theory
into the institutions they're telling
you that they're going to
give grants to people that spread these
bad ideas then the fbi is saying okay
we're gonna have an office of diversity
and inclusion and just i mean really
think about it for a second like joking
aside
do you think that any of these things
are gonna make us more
tolerant like is there any reason to
believe that critical race theory is
there any
reason to believe that the ideas of
wokeness and intersectionality
and social justice do any does anything
happening right now feel
more tolerant do we feel more diverse do
we think that this is healing
do we think that this is bringing
together people of course not it's
destroying everything and that's
actually what it's designed to do
and it's being imported by a guy who
doesn't know which way is up
uh so that's enough on biden for now
let's talk about that trump guy
and and to the youtube gods please don't
ban me
for talking about the president of the
united states you guys made a whole
bunch of money on while you were
promoting him
until you decided not to promote him
anymore donald trump
went on sean hannity on fox news last
night for
for a pretty extensive interview and
let's just watch this one little bite
so he's going to be 79 years old that is
not
old i know many people in their late 80s
that are just as good as they were
years ago i spoke to one who's 92 years
old he said i feel better than i did
20 years ago 78 79 is not
old but he you know look i i don't think
it's even appropriate for me to comment
on that
it sort of speaks for itself maybe
people can
make their own determination i know that
if it were me
uh they would be up and down going crazy
right but uh i had an instance where
on a slippery slippery ramp piece of
steel
very steep and very long no railings no
nothing and it was pouring at west point
and the last thing i want to do is go
down because when gerald ford went down
it was not good
now when biden went down the three the
press didn't cover it i mean if you look
at
well in fairness as ade said that the
wind it was very windy the wind might
have blown them over
did the wind ever blow you over when you
well air force one is a very big plane
and usually what they try and do is
shield the wind you know when they park
it you can turn it at angles and so you
don't
ever have too much i've never seen too
much wind
you can get a little windy but not the
kind of wind that blows you over
but if you look at mainstream media or
as you say lame stream
media they didn't cover that if that
were a republican
in particular it was me that would be
the biggest story for the rest of
the year i gotta tell you guys i miss
him
i know i'm not going to get invited to
hollywood parties
that's all right that's right we host
parties here of dissidents and radicals
um i miss him and actually everything he
said there and yes is he a little more
bronze than usual and the hair is like a
little bit crazier
and the way he speaks is still as
stilted and strange the patterns all
that stuff
but man basically in that minute and a
half clip he told you the truth
like it was the truth the media would
have went bananas if he had fallen down
the steps three times right and they
pretty much ignored it or excused it or
said it had something to do with the
wind but the line
i've never seen too much wind it can get
a little windy and then i think he said
not enough to knock you down something
like that like he's
closer to telling the truth than anyone
we have in politics right now and that
is
just a bizarre reality
it is i i don't think i think it is
quite possible that
within our lifetimes we will not see
anyone in a in a political sense at
least
not right now let's say for the next 10
years because lord only knows which way
the
whole world is going to go that will be
remotely as truthful as him right like
it's not like they were discussing
something so important right there but
like
for all the craziness about the way he
speaks like the truth is sort of under
it
versus what everyone else in politics
does which is try to pretend they're a
great person and then they just lie and
[ __ ] to you
uh he also made a point that you know 79
is not that old it actually
isn't in 2021 right like there are so
many
uh medications there there are new ways
of thinking new ways of living we know
so much more about health and diet and
all of these things that of course
of course you could be bright and
vibrant
and doing incredible things well into
your 90s when i lived in new york city
my
my grandmother's first cousin so this
was like my
great aunt uh or something like that my
guess she was a great or she was a
cousin of some sort
anyway she lived till she was about 97
and when she was about 95 i was out
walking the dog it was like 3 a.m in new
york city
and i'm walking the dog and i see from
the distance sort of this person
stumbling down the street and it was my
cousin barbara
who was at the time about 95 she was a
piano teacher still teaching all day
long
and she had a couple martinis with
friends and she was wandering home drunk
on the upper west side of new york city
like you can live a long
vibrant life i don't think that's
exactly what we're seeing with the you
know who
uh anyway it's interesting that that
hannity put
trump on because he obviously is getting
a little more involved right now
and i think what's interesting is you
know there's such a massive vacuum
on the right side of things right so i
think desantis who we're going to get
into in just a second
i think he's kind of filling the vacuum
at some level
but as i've said for a while you know
what what the republicans or
conservatives or anyone non-woke
whatever it is
what they're going to have to figure out
is well how do we get the fighter who's
going to do
all of the all of the nasty stuff all
the wwe style moves when
you know when the referee's looking the
other way who's going to hit someone
with a chair the way trump would
while also being statesmanlike because
that's what a lot of people said to me a
lot of people said well dave i
understand trump's policies aren't bad
and i understand that the other guys are
bananas
but it's the way he speaks it's the it's
the things he talks about to grab him by
the [ __ ]
well okay well how are you going to get
that because if you just take a regular
guy and try to put him
through that machine john mccain mitt
romney you know you lose
so that's the negotiation i would say
for people on the right but that's
actually a good segue
let's talk a little bit about what's
going on with ron desantis over in
florida
so they just passed an anti-riot
bill in florida and let me let me read a
little bit here
this is from the official press release
governor ron desantis was joined by
legislative leadership and law
enforcement officials from across the
state
to sign the combating public disorder
act into law
the bill hb1 takes a robust approach
to uphold the rule of law stand with
those serving in law enforcement
and enforce florida's zero tolerance
policy
for violent and disorderly assemblies
okay so what's
interesting about that is that's
obviously in reaction to what's
happening all over the country but
particularly in minneapolis
right now the basic idea is that yes you
can protest but you can't burn
things down you can't destroy property
and you can't
murder and assault people that's in
essence what they passed here
then desantis gave a press conference
and let me
read you just a little bit he said if
you riot you are going to
jail and you are going to have to spend
time in jail
if you ins assault law enforcement in a
violent assembly
you are definitely going to go to jail
you burn down somebody's business
the penalties are going to be very swift
and immediate
yes that is exactly what we need and
that is called
leadership right that is called
leadership most of us whatever our
political differences are
we want to live in a country of law and
order right we want the basic idea
of you can't steal from someone you
can't destroy their stuff
you can't attack law enforcement those
are the basic things we want
and then we can figure out okay are
there little tweaks we can do within
that
to make things better or whatever word
you want to use for that
but then uh after desantis spoke
the flora florida sheriff from polk
county
uh grady judd well he had a message for
all of the new people
on their way to florida right now we're
a special
place and there are millions and
millions of people who like to come here
and quite frankly we like to have them
here
so we only want to share one thing as
you move in hundreds a day
welcome to florida but don't register to
vote and vote the stupid way you did up
north you'll get what they got
there's a reason that this place is fun
there's a reason why we have a 49-year
low crime rate
truth that's what you just heard there
truth kind of like trump before there
are some people saying something true i
cannot believe i'm sitting here
telling you that trump is now the the
grand arbiter of
of truth in public discourse these days
but what uh sheriff grady judge just
said there was
absolutely true this is a great place
we've built it right we're doing the
right thing
sure you mocked us for florida man over
the years but we
put a primacy on liberty on freedom all
of that good stuff that you're now
coming to sharon and you're fleeing
places like san francisco as i've
mentioned to you guys when i was in
uh miami a couple weeks ago no this was
uh this was february it's a little more
than a couple weeks ago
uh the amount of people fleeing san
francisco silicon valley
to now set up shop in
miami in broader florida but mostly
miami it's extraordinary we're actually
moving
locals we're moving the entire company
down there um
he's so right when he says don't vote
the stupid way
they did up north like this is sort of
the challenge for the free states there
is nobody like please somebody show me
the people
that are fleeing the red states because
if you listen to the mainstream media
the corporate
press as it were uh it would sound like
oh my god people would have to flee
these open states because everyone's
dying and it's horrible so people must
be
fleeing florida they must be fleeing
texas
and they must be moving to safe havens
of freedom like california
and new york i can't find one example of
that can somebody please
find me an example of somebody that was
like oh my god what's happening in
florida
is just horrible i can't live amongst
these people anymore with their freedom
and their open
uh economies and all of that stuff i'm
moving to california
like can you possibly imagine that the
only person who i know that moved
to los angeles and the entire thing is
my director connor and he moved from
seattle
okay he moved from seattle he didn't
move to he didn't move
from he didn't move from texas you know
what i'm saying he moved from chop okay
he was the number one real estate agent
in chop and he moved down here
to los angeles so you see my point
people i think i think everybody gets it
and
i love you florida i can't wait to be in
you again um
all right one more for you guys because
i just saw this
and aoc is she's just terrible she's
just
absolutely terrible what do you want me
to say there's no way i can analyze it
more than that this woman is an
idiot she is a buffoon she's a she's a
character actor
who they selected for the part of
playing aoc
and she just gave a speech about climate
change and just
listen really just listen to the pure
drivel
that is aoc client the climate crisis
is a crisis born of injustice and it is
a crisis born of the pursuit of profit
at any and
all human and ecological cost
which means that we must recognize in
legislation
that the trampling of indigenous rights
is
a cause of climate change the the
trampling of racial justice
is a cause of climate change because we
are allowing people
and we are allowing ourselves to make
sure to we are allowing folks
to deny ourselves human rights and deny
people the right to health care
the right to housing and education she
just said absolutely nothing
those are words that were put together
in something remotely close to sentences
but she said
absolutely nothing that was remotely
close to a sensible thought
at all the quote the trampling of racial
justice
is a cause of climate change do you see
what they do they combine
all of their pet ridiculous issues that
mostly they imagine
and then they link them to some much
other some much bigger thing
that they want to do so the trampling of
racial justice is about climate change
and guess what
if you let her use her green new deal or
her new green deal or whatever the hell
it is and you let her take enough money
out of the
american economy to do whatever it is
she wants to do then
things will be better but she really
just
babbles completely and coherently and
that reminded me of something
i personally believe that u.s americans
are unable to do so because
some people out there in our nation
don't have that and i believe that our
education like such as in south africa
and
the iraq everywhere like such as and
i believe that they should our education
over here
in the us should help the u.s or should
help
south africa and should help the iraq
and the asian countries
so we will be able to build up our
future
i don't know what happened to that lady
but i would vote
for her before i would vote for aoc if
that girl will run
in aoc's district i will support her i
will donate
money to her i will put her on the show
i will use every connection that i have
in this world
to do everything i can to have her get
rid of aoc because whatever she just
said about the maps
and south africa and the whole other
thing was a hell of a lot more sensible
than
anything that aoc just babbled in that
ridiculous press conference
on that note people i've enjoyed the
show today i said it was going to be our
longest ever didn't we're 28 minutes i
tried to keep them to 24.
we ball parked it we ball parked it uh
obviously i have a whole bunch to do
related to locals got a bunch of press
coming up
and all that oh and by the way the
reason i wanted to play that aoc clip
was not just
to mock aoc who is so mockable but
uh you know i've long believed that
there are ways we can do things about
the environment and i think most
say right-leaning people don't think
there's nothing that could be done about
the environment or that we couldn't do
things a little bit better everything
else they just don't want giant
government programs to be the answer so
you know what we're going to do about it
people
we're going to do a friday paddle show
this week with bjorn lomberg
benji backer and alex epstein talking
about how private companies and perhaps
even public-private partnerships
could have something to do with fixing
some of the environment and we don't
just have to give
aoc a whole bunch of power so she can
lecture us about cow farts
and systemic injustice on that note guys
uh part one of my interview with andrew
gruel chef andrew gruel uh it's the
guy's just great and if you haven't seen
his pictures on twitter what this guy's
cooking up is just amazing
and he's fighting all of the draconian
lockdowns here in california like
talk about somebody that like stepped
into the role that they were supposed to
be in
uh part one is up on youtube right now
part uh the full episode of course is up
ad free at rubinreport.locals.com and i
just want to say one other thing
about what we did with locals the
announcement we made this morning you
know a couple weeks ago
actually after i had david saxon on the
show we had known at that point the deal
was coming together
and i taped an extra segment with him
where he talked about why he invested
in locals and what he thought were doing
i posted that on locals for subscribers
only
and not one person leaked it it didn't
get leaked to the media it didn't get
leaked anywhere
and that shows you that there is a way
to rebuild community online
and that if you bring together people
who have some
even vague sense of a similar future
that they want to get to that you can
build it so we have built it
and if you build it they will come so i
hope you will join us at
and as i said we now have a yearly
subscription so if you want to get two
months free you can do that
right now that's it busy day hope you
enjoyed the show there was a lot there
was a lot there
but you know the last couple days i've
been sort of more annoyed and angry and
a little
frustrated about the world and
everything else like if that aoc thing
and the girl that i'm going to vote for
to replace aoc if that didn't put a
smile on your face like you got to talk
to somebody
anyway have a great day everybody oh and
it's 4 20 so
do what you got to do if you have quack